do people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up yes rapunzel rapunzel let down your
hair and while you're at it why don't
you tell us how you managed to keep seen
for 18 years despite being locked up in
a tower that must have been super tough
but luckily you had Pascal to keep you
company you may be a Disney princess but
you suffered a great deal because of
your title if the choice I've been yours
would you have opted out on being a
royal being a Disney Princess might seem
like a breeze but heavy lies the crown
our favorite Disney Princesses struggled
to live a life of peace and bliss but
luckily many of them got the happily
ever after they deserved you're watching
the 10 dark secrets behind being a
Disney Princess
Trust doesn't come easy Disney
Princesses learn firsthand how important
it is to ask questions and check back
this is because they usually get
betrayed by those closest to them poor
Rapunzel was much too trusting at the
beginning of her life she believed every
word mother Gothel spoon fed her but she
didn't learn her lesson the first time
around she was also betrayed by her best
friend Cassandra so if you're a disney
princess you better keep your guard up
your image is everything when you're
born under the watchful eye of the
public you need to learn to act a
certain way princess Atta kid is
everything and if you botch up your
image you risk losing the faith of your
people Disney Princesses often go
through an identity crisis because
they're not allowed to be themselves
before running off to war Mulan was
being groomed to become a dutiful wife
but that just wasn't her style luckily
she was courageous enough to stay true
to herself fit in or stand out
conforming to society's standards can
seem like an impossible task when you're
the black sheep of the family every
single Disney Princess was forced to
stand out because they couldn't fit in
Belle was seen as crazy because she
loved reading and didn't want to marry
Gaston
Meredith faced her mother's wrath
because she was gifted in archery and
didn't want a husband
and where Elsa had to run away from home
to finally be yourself in that gorgeous
ice castle your only friends are animals
it's a well-known fact that Royals have
a hard time making friends after all
they can't just walk to the park and
hang out with the kids from the
neighborhood being a Disney princess
means living a sheltered life I've never
even been outside the palace walls so it
comes as no surprise that most of the
Disney Princesses don't have any human
friends where would our princesses be
without their faithful animal companions
Rapunzel had fiscal Ariel had flounder
and Cinderella had her mice if it
weren't for them our princesses would
have gone completely bonkers you're
never safe another dark truth to being a
Disney Princess is not having the luxury
of safety evil forces seek them out the
very second they're born mother fossil
came for baby Rapunzel and snatched her
from her crib
Maleficent crashed Aurora's christening
and put a devastating curse on her
Ursula saw Ariel out and manipulated her
and Snow White's very own stepmother
hired a huntsman to carve out her heart
we're surprised that the princesses
haven't developed high levels of
paranoia marriage is a must it wasn't
until recently that Disney Princesses
were given the freedom to marry at their
own will Snow White Cinderella Aurora
Ariel
Tiana Belle and Jasmine got married by
the end of their Disney movies despite
being super young since these are modern
times Disney is coping with the changes
by giving us princesses like Merida
Moana and Elsa not only did they escape
marriage but they also managed to stay
single throughout their movies this dark
secret is slowly coming to light which
is why Disney heroines no longer have to
tie the knot your life gets planned up
for you anyone who is born into a royal
family already has their life planned
out for them kings and queens are
notorious for setting up their children
with other Royals anything from arranged
marriages to the clothes on their backs
is calculated this can be very
frustrating especially if you have some
dreams of your own Ariel was supposed to
be the perfect little mermaid but she
refused to follow her father's life plan
it got her into some trouble but hey
following your heart is priceless you
might not have parents growing up with
your family is a gift that money can't
buy so despite having all the riches a
princess could ever one many of them
find themselves parentless Merida Moana
Mulan Rapunzel and Aurora still have
both their parents but the rest of the
princesses either have one or none and
even then Rapunzel and Aurora didn't get
the chance to be raised by their parents
nightmarish childhoods
most Disney Princesses didn't have happy
childhoods Jasmine lost her mother and
was forced to grow up friendless inside
the palace walls
tiana worked her childhood away after
losing her father
Cinderella was enslaved by her step
family after losing both her parents and
Snow White was forced to run away from
home after both her parents passed away
the dark truth is that Disney Princesses
grow up too quickly everyone thinks you
need saving if you've watched Ralph Rex
the Internet then you know that there's
one thing every Disney Princess despises
do people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up whether you know how to defend
yourself or not the world will always
think you need saving and that the dark
truth now that you know what you know
would you still want to be a Disney
Princess sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap thanks for watching the
thing subscribe to our Channel and give
this video a big thumbs up we'll see you
next time
[Music]